Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Oder Sie mögen nicht so gern Accounts löschen, weil Daten sind ja auch Geld wert.
Ja, richtig.
Also nicht die Daten, sondern die Zahl.
Genau, und also inzwischen bin ich halt raus aus dem Studio 4Z, also richtig den Auslöser. Also ich war erst schon verärgert über diese neuen AGBs, die wir halt da gemacht haben. Die fand ich schon einfach nicht so toll, bin aber noch so ein bisschen drin geblieben. Und dann der Auslöser, das ich rausgebe, halt dann das, was sie vorhin auch schon zitiert hat, mit diesen Kiffer-Bildern, das war es beispielsweise online. Da habe ich mir gedacht, nee Leute, das kann doch gar nicht sein. Einst schon dieser Tonfaktor, es ist ja so schön, dass wir das jetzt endlich können und so. Also ich habe jetzt keine Kiffer-Bilder und auch so irgendwie die betrunkenen Tati-Fotos halten sich irgendwie auch in Grenzen. Aber wenn, also ich habe sowieso selber auch gar keine reingestellt, das finde ich auch so schlimm. Dann stellen andere Fotos rein und können einen darauf verlinken. Am besten gleich noch auf dem Gesicht und dann steht da, ja dieser Mensch ist auf so und so Fotos verlinkt. Naja und dann war halt so das Prozedere, bis man auf Studio4Z erstmal raus ist. Dann gibt man hier in der Einstellung ja Account löschen und dann kommt noch die Rückfrage, ja bist du jetzt wirklich sicher und dann kommt noch mal, ja überleg doch mal, weil wenn mir die Freunde und die Frage, wissen wir doch gar nicht so schlimm und wir geben auch gar nichts raus, dann muss man noch mal bestätigen und dann noch mal eine E-Mail. Also irgendwann war man da mal raus, aber man hat ziemlich viel Arbeit, bis sie einen endlich mal da rauslassen und dann noch so was anderes, von wegen, dass der Personalchef da reinguckt, ich, ein Freund von mir arbeitet bei Porsche.
Wie alle anderen in Stuttgart auch wahrscheinlich, der lässt es dann bei dem anderen aus dem Autobau.
Nee und da war es halt so irgendwie, der ist halt in so einer Filiale tätig und dann hieß es, kam irgendwie eine Trafikantin zum Forschungsgespräch und danach kam dann halt der Chef zu meinem Freund so, ja das war ja so ganz nett und jetzt gucken sie doch mal in dieses komische Studie-VZ rein, da sind sie ja auch angemeldet, ob wir die auch wirklich annehmen können. Und da haben sie halt Texte über sich gefunden und dann hat sie an ihre Stelle auch bekommen. Ja aber einfach, dass da halt so nachgeschaut wird und ich finde das irgendwie pervers. Ja also gut, man möchte so als Arbeitgeber vielleicht wissen, wer das für ein Mensch so ist, ja, aber dann da so sich dafür zu interessieren, ob es da zu viele besoffene Party-Fotos gibt oder irgendetwas in der Richtung. Ich meine, das interessiert den doch gar nicht zu interessieren, ja. Also so lange ich morgens pünktlich auf der Matte stehe und mich konzentriert da arbeiten kann, hat mein Arbeitgeber doch mein Privatleben eigentlich in Scheißdreck zu interessieren. Und das nächste ist ja, die Chefs haben ja früher bestimmt auch nicht, haben auch großartig Partys gemacht, haben davon halt keine Fotos in der Internet gestellt. Es wird ja so hingestellt, als wenn jemand sich mal besäuft, oder so, dass der dann gleich ein Unmensch ist, den man dann nicht mehr einstellen kann.
Also ist das eigentlich ein legitimes Mittel, ich hab ja von Arbeitsrechten so wirklich viel Ahnung, aber dass der Personalchef da reingucken kann, beziehungsweise der Personalchef nicht mal selber, sondern irgendjemand anders sagen kann, hier gucken sie doch mal an dieses Studi-Dingsbums und recherchieren sie doch mal alles über diese Person.
Das haben die Leute öffentlich gemacht, also vom rein Rechlichen her. Es gibt da nichts einzuwenden gegen, müssen halt die Leute sich selbst überlegen. Wir haben da übrigens auch, wir hatten diesen Punkt auch, wir haben ja so ein paar Sachen mal uns schon vorher so Nachrichten quasi gemacht dazu, so eine Kurz-Nachrichten. Und da ist diese Geschichte mit diesem Personalchef, den natürlich einmal, dass die Profile bei Google sind, aber eben auch, dass mittlerweile in diesem Netzwerk nachgeschaut wird.
Also mir ist neulich, vielleicht kann ich jetzt bei der Gelegenheit erzählen, mir ist neulich tatsächlich mal so ein Fall passiert, wo sich eine Studentin beworben hat und sie hatte in ihrem Blog sehr offen darüber geschrieben, dass sie schwanger ist. Tja, das war natürlich unangenehm, weil sie hatte beim Bewerbungsgeschäft belogen, was du tun darfst. Das war natürlich eher unangenehm für sie.
Der Careerkiller Social Network wird in den nächsten Jahren das weitaus größere Problem gegenüber dem Careerkiller Google werden. Mittlerweile ist auch bei den hinterletzten Personalverantwortlichen in den Firmen angekommen, dass man bei Bewerbungen nicht nur Google anwirft, sondern auch mal die üblichen Social Networks durchsieht. Dabei sind es oft nicht die eigenen Sauv-Party-Fotos, die zum Verhängnis werden, sondern die von Kumpels eingestellten und dann verlinkten.
Haben wir ganz genauso von dir gehört. Es ist gut, dass du das noch mal bestätigst.
Ja, und ich finde es auch so ein bisschen so, man kann ja gegen diese Verlängerung auch irgendwie so nicht wirklich was tun. Ich habe auch so das Gefühl, es gibt ja schon die Funktion von wegen Link entfernen oder Protest anmelden oder so. Aber ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass man da steht, kann ich das jetzt irgendwie meinem Freund zumuten, dass ich ihm hingehe und ihm quasi auf diesen Umweg sage, von wegen, das Foto hätte ich jetzt gerne nicht.
Naja, aber dein Freund hat es auch reingestellt.
Er hätte dich fragen können. Genau.
Also nicht nur fragen können, hätte er es auf möglichen Fall müssen.
Es ist einfach so dieser Drang. Es ist alles so einfach. Und selbst der schlimmste Dau kann damit so ein paar Klicks alles Mögliche reinstellen und weiß vielleicht gar nicht, was er da wirklich tut.
Würdest du jetzt deinen Freunden abberaten, so ein Netzwerk zu nutzen und da auch sich zu präsentieren?
Also im Prinzip würde ich da auf jeden Fall schon immer abraten. Das Einzige, für was es halt gut ist, ist, mit Leuten wirklich in Kontakt zu kommen, von denen man irgendwie gerade überhaupt keine Daten mehr hat und die man irgendwann mal irgendwo getroffen hat.
Aber dazu musst du ja erstmal Daten reinstellen, ne?
Richtig, genau. Und das finde ich das Problem. Ich habe einfach keine Lust auf diese ganzen Spielchen. Wobei ich jetzt allerdings schon wieder die Befürchtung hege, ich fange jetzt im Herbst an zu studieren, dass ich dann wieder genötigt werde von wegen wie, du hast keins und dann kann ich ja gar nicht mit dir. Aber mein Plan, falls dann die Nötigung zu schlimm wird, ist halt so ein Fake-Profil reinzustellen, was ja dann nach den neuen AGBs bei StudiVZ auch ganz groß war.
Na, das würde er dann gegen die AGB verstoßen.
Ja, aber na gut, wenn da Leute drin sind, die heißen Mima Mulliland oder so, die sind immer noch drin und...
Kostet ja eine Strafe von 6000 Euro, wenn sie dich damit kriegen.
Das wusste ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch noch gar nicht.
Ich muss mich mit meinem Klarnamen anmelden.
Das ist ganz interessant, dass man, weil das Telemediengesetz sieht nämlich ausdrücklich vor, dass man auch Dienste Pseudonym nutzen kann. Es wäre mal interessant, ob das nicht sogar im Widerspruch steht.
Ja, dass die AGB rechtmäßig sind, ist ja von vielen Seiten bestritten worden. Also es ging ja auch, denke ich, viel durch die Blogs. Also ich glaube, da hat sich Studiforz ja doch ein echtes Eigentor geschossen. Die haben eigentlich seit Anbeginn eine unglaublich schlechte Presse. Die tun aber auch das Beste dafür.
Die haben sich sehr amateurhaft. Da gibts so einige Possen.
Matthias, danke dir für deinen Anruf. Sehr gerne. Und der nächste am Telefon ist Benedikt aus Düsseldorf. Hallo nach Düsseldorf.
Morgen.
Moin, wie spät ist denn bei dir schon? Wo bist du unterwegs?
Leider nur, also zum Glück nur im Studiforz. Weil, wie soll man sagen, meine Meinung nach ist das im Endeffekt, benutzt man Studiforz nur deswegen, weil die Leute zu dumm sind, irgendwie sich eine eigene Seite zu schreiben, um die Bilder da drauf zu stellen.
Ah, also quasi der Ersatz für eine eigene Homepage.
Genau, man macht einfach Fotos und bis man die dann mal irgendwie per TD rumgibt, das dauert viel zu lange oder funktioniert eh nicht. Und einen FDP zu betreiben ist auch viel zu kompliziert.
Ich kenne das von MySpace, dass auch viele Leute, die irgendwie eine MySpace-Seite haben, die einfach zu faul sind, eine eigene Homepage zu machen. Das Problem ist, dass man von diesen MySpace-Seiten echt Augenkrebs kriegt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie so gewollt ist von denen, ob das gar nicht anders geht.
Naja, und ist das eine Sicherheitslöcke. Also dadurch, dass so viele Möglichkeiten dem MySpace-Seite gegeben wird, haben sich natürlich auch wieder Leute gefunden, die das ausnutzen. Da gab es diese berühmte Seite, wo jemand Microsoft-Updates anbote. Das waren dann, also bei Trojaner war das eine gehackte Seite. Das ist natürlich auch wieder umstritten.
Es gibt ja dann auch so diese netten Pixel-Seiten, das ist ja im Endeffekt genau dasselbe, dass man halt einfach so dann in diese Richtung geht.
Aber jetzt, unabhängig davon, dass das quasi Internetseite oder eigene Homepage für Idioten ist, der Vorgang bleibt doch derselbe. Ich stelle Dinge aus meinem Leben online, also sei es Fotos aus dem Urlaub oder von irgendeiner Familienfete oder von meinen Leuten aus der Klasse oder was auch immer. Und die stehen dann da im Netz und irgendjemand anders kann, ohne dass ich das eigentlich möchte, über mich Informationen sammeln.
Ja, aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob ich jetzt im Endeffekt in ein Social Network einsetze oder einfach nur auf einem FDP, wo man dann noch Benutzerdaten verbraucht. Oder Passwortschützen. Die ich die Person dann im Endeffekt nur geben kann.
Also du denkst schon, dass es damit zu tun ist, dass es für normale User einfach zu benutzen ist? Ja, also die Sauheit des Menschen. Ich denke auch, das kann man glaube ich auch gerade bei so sehr jungen Leuten sehen. Das ist einfach der Effekt, dass die einfachen Funktionen und die praktischen Funktionen genutzt werden. Dann braucht man halt sich nicht eigene Netze bauen oder eigene Infrastruktur.
Ich glaube, das hat nichts zu tun mit sehr junge Leute oder sehr alte Leute oder normale Leute. Wenn sich mein technisches Verständnis darauf beschränkt, eine E-Mail abzuschicken und eine Suchmaschine zu benutzen und ich mich bitte nicht damit beschäftigen möchte, wie ich jetzt keine Ahnung, eine HTTP-Webseite programmiere, dann ist das die einfachste Variante, um schnell irgendwas ins Netz zu pusten und nicht erst das online zu machen.
Es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit, einfach einen Blog anzulegen. Es gibt ja mittlerweile genug Anbieter, wo du auch kostenlos irgendwie einen Blog machen kannst. Und es machen ja auch viele. Und wahrscheinlich sind Blogs die fortgeschrittene Variante von Social Networks.
Ja, aber im Social Network hast du ja den Vorteil zu sehen, was ich mache dann an und sehe, oh, CCC ist auch jemand online. Zack, ich weiß, dass sie da sind. Ruf ich mal an oder schicke ich den im Nachricht oder was auch immer. Das habe ich in einem Blog nicht.
Das stimmt natürlich, ja.
Bist du noch da?
Sind wir jetzt komplett am Thema bis zur Erschöpfung ausgekippt und es ist nichts mehr da? Nein. Benedict, wie geht es denn dir mit diesen Datenschutzeinwänden, die immer wieder auch von Datenschützern kommen, die sagen, Leute, stell den Kram nicht ins Internet.
Ja, es ist halt im Endeffekt, also in meinem Profil steht wirklich nur so das Allerwenigste drinnen und der Name, soweit es geht, hat auch einfach abgekürzt.
Aber verdammt, dann funktionieren doch diese ganzen Netze nicht.
Ich kann doch keiner finden.
Ja, das ist ja im Endeffekt das, was ich will. Also so gesehen, es ist einfach nur, dass wir da, dass die Leute, die irgendwie mit mir zusammen studieren, dass die halt wissen, ja, okay, der heißt vielleicht so. Das war einfach noch meine alte Schule drin. Und da kriege ich dann irgendwelche Mitteilungen von Leuten, die jetzt in die fünfte Klasse reinkommen, dass ob ich nicht doch deren Freund sein möchte, wo ich mich dann auffrage, so, okay, ich kenne dich nicht.
Aber kannst du nicht einfach den Leuten aus deiner Uni irgendwie deine E-Mail-Adresse geben? Also früher, zu meiner Studienzeit, da gab es halt einfach eine E-Mail-Liste, also E-Mail-Verteiler oder so.
Okay, aber interessante These. MySpace und sonstige Seiten sind was für Leute, die zu faul sind, eine eigene Homepage zu betreiben. Danke, Benedikt. Chaosradio auf Fritz 134, Soziale Netzwerke ist unser Thema. Ihr könnt gerne mit uns diskutieren, 0331 70 97 110. Wir schalten rüber zu Mona und Lisa ins Hausboot. Den wollte ich schon immer mal bringen. Nein, Unsinn. Hallo Matthias. Hallo. Von wo rufst du an?
Aus Liepe.
Aus Liepe? Ist das hier um die Ecke?
Na ja.
Auf jeden Fall in Brandenburg, also nicht in Düsseldorf oder in Stuttgart oder so.
Wollte ich damit sagen. Bist du sozial vernetzwerkt?
Ich war nicht mehr so doll wie früher.
Jetzt hat man doch noch Weikett, so eine Band und so weiter.
Aber davor ziemlich stark.
Was war denn der Einstiegspunkt? Internet.
Nein, ich meine, was hat dich angezogen? Was war der Punkt, warum du dir die Accounts zugelegt hast?
Na ja, ich komme vom Dorf, sagen wir mal so. Und vorher wusste ich davon nichts. Und als dann sozusagen eine Freundin mir gesagt hat, ich bin hier bei Rockzone oder so, und da hat es bei mir eigentlich so angefangen, dann hat man da wieder Leute kennenlernt und da wieder Leute kennenlernt. Und dann hat man dann sozusagen vergrößert.
Weil jetzt bin ich ja auf MySpace, Schülerforzeit, Studiforzeit, japi.wii.it.de, das ist halt irgendwo das selbe.
Machst du sonst eigentlich noch irgendwas, außer Nachrichten checken und gucken, ob sich jemand gemeldet hat?
Na, wie gesagt, jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich bin da zwar noch angemeldet, aber wenn... Also man kann es ja, man kann es sich nicht ganz einfach machen, indem man einfach die Seiten, man kann ja einschalten, ja, wenn ich eine Nachricht kriege, schickt es mir eine Nachricht, per E-Mail sozusagen. Und wenn ich nach Hause komme, gucke ich einfach bei meinem E-Bill-Postgang da ein und gucke, ja, gut, ich hab bei MySpace eine Nachricht und bei Schüler-Forzit.
Und dann kuck ich auf die beiden Seiten ruf, Antworten, ja.
Und dann hat sich das auch...
Das ist ja auch noch so eine Unsitte, dass man die Sachen da nicht per E-Mail, also die Nachricht gleich bekommen hat, sondern nur diese Metainformation, also da ist eine E-Mail. Warum können wir nicht einfach gleich die E-Mail weiterleiten? Aber dann wäre wahrscheinlich der Sinn und Zweck von so einem Netz wieder. Keine Werbung und so.
Naja, stimmt wohl.
Irgendwie schon, aber ich kenne zum Beispiel Leute, die ich einfach bloß bei Myspace kennenlerne. Die kennen ihren wirklichen E-Mail-Adress auch gar nicht.
Könnte man anhand der Namen deines Profils, also wenn du Pseudonyme benutzt oder deinen wirklichen Namen, die verschiedenen Accounts, die du über die sozialen Netzwerke hinweg hast, vernetzen? Also ist es klar, dass du dieselbe Person bist bei dir? Weil du wahrscheinlich auch die Band promoten willst in eurer Musik?
Das mache ich nur über MySpace.
Kennst du spock.com? Diese sogenannte Menschensuchmaschine?
Also ich habe schon davon gehört, ja, aber sonst...
spock.com ist ja so ein Neuprojekt, wo man versuchen will, die verschiedenen sozialen Netzwerke und auch noch andere Internetquellen zu aggregieren. Man könnte ja damit deine verschiedenen Profile zusammenholen. Und hier sollen ja die Menschen helfen, dass man eben diese Ergebnisse von spock.com verbessert und verschlagwortet und eben Bilder zuordnet. Wie findest du so? Wäre dir das Recht, wenn die sozusagen diese Suchmaschine tut? Mit deinem Namen und mit deinem Profil? Also gefunden werden ist dir das wichtiger als... Naja, eben die Frage, wer kann das alles sehen? Was ist für dich das Wichtige?
Also ich finde eigentlich Leute kennenzulernen. Für mich ist es wirklich ein Portal, um Leute kennenzulernen.
Ist es auch flirten?
Wie bitte?
Weil, also, schon, also, hat schon, spielt schon eine wichtige Rolle. Und auch sich ein bisschen so präsentieren. Und, also, sozusagen Kritik zu kriegen, weil man jetzt, seht ihr, also, ich setze nicht unbedingt die Bilder, die Freunde von mir rinstehen, also verlinken mit. Also, ich hab bis jetzt noch kein Problem damit, weil, naja, ich wiss nicht, für Leute, die vielleicht im Beruf leben und, und ein seriöses, nach außen seriös entscheiden müssen und dann irgendwelche Saufbilder da drin sind, ist das natürlich so eine Sache. Aber ich, erstens bin ich arbeitslos. Also, jetzt seit kurzem zwinge, lebe ich mich noch ein bisschen aus.
Und ein zukünftiger Chef würde bei dir auch nicht unbedingt was finden, was dir jetzt super peinlich wäre.
Es sei denn, er mag deine Musik nicht.
Also, das könnte er auf jeden Fall zutreffen, weil er schon ein bisschen so Death-Metal-mäßig ist.
Es gibt ja nur die coolen Chefs, die das mögen.
Ne, aber, denn das ist, also diese Kritik hat, wenn man ein Bild drin hat und einfach mal zu hören, ja, das sieht gut aus oder so. Und die verschiedenen Sachen, zum Beispiel wie alt.de, da geht es nach dem Alter, wie mich Leute nach dem Alter schätzen. Total interessant und macht mir auch Spaß, andere Leute zu einschätzen. Man findet dann immer raus, wie jung die Mädchen eigentlich alle früher ausgesehen hatten.
Und die waren auch wirklich so jung.
Und jetzt sehen sie alt aus wie 20 und sind manchmal bis 15.
Wir halten mal unterm Strich fest, weil sich durch soziale Netzwerke zu klicken, ist auch ein wunderbarer Zeitvertrag. Man kann prima Zeit tot schlagen damit.
Man hat noch was zu lachen. Da sind manchmal Typen dabei, wo man denkt, oh Gott, wie können die sowas in den Internet stellen? Für die Band ist es für mich ziemlich wichtig, weil anders kommt man eigentlich fast gar nicht mehr ran. Meistens tritt jemand an dich ran und sagt, lass mal zusammen spielen, als ob man anders noch hingeht und fragt, wie sieht es denn aus?
Der Selbstleifer war eben alle anderen auch dabei.
Matthias, zum Abschluss mein kleines Death Metal-Herz. Das neugierige heißt die Kapelle.
Sorry, my mom called me for dinner.
Sorry, my mom called me for dinner?
Das muss man aufschreiben.
Bandname der Woche, fällt mir sehr. Ich wünsche euch die große Weltkarriere und ein Auftritt beim Redding Festival. Wann auch immer. Vielleicht tut es auf Full Force Bühne. Danke Matthias. 0331 70 97 110. Soziale Netzwerke sind was für Leute, die zu doof oder zu faul sind, sich eine eigene Webseite zu programmieren. Soziale Netzwerke sind was für Leute, die ganz viel Zeit haben, die flirten wollen, die sonstige Dinge sich einschätzen lassen wollen, sich komische Bilder angucken. Unsoziale Netzwerke sind prima, zum Beispiel für den Filialleiter von Porsche in Stuttgart, weil der sagt, wir haben eine neue Mitarbeiterin, guck doch mal nach, was sie sonst alles so schon getrieben hat.
Und soziale Netzwerke sind auch was ganz Tolles für Männer. Guck dir mich an. Na ja, es gab zum Beispiel auch eine Geschichte, wo sich die Männer-Community, oder habt ihr mit denen schon gehört? Nee. Ganz schnell, wenn ihr uns noch Mails schreiben wollt, schickt eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und zum Nachlesen gibt es auch nochmal alles in unserem Wiki. Da haben schon ganz viele Leute eingetragen. Auch nochmal vielen Dank dafür. Und ansonsten möchte ich auch noch auf unseren außerplanmäßigen Podcast hinweisen, sozusagen. Das ist der Chaosradio Express, den der Tim hauptsächlich macht. Und da gibt es alle Themen, die hier so nicht im Radio Platz gefunden haben. Das sind teilweise sehr technische Themen, sehr abgefahrene Themen. Ist ein bisschen was, wenn ihr länger Zeit habt zum Zuhören. Sehr empfehlenswert. Alles unter chaosradio.ccc.de Schön überbrüht.
Jetzt habe ich ihn gefunden.
Sehr gut.
Eine Liste mit 57.000 MySpace-Accounts taucht im Internet auf.
Die 700 Stalker hätten wir gern.
Nee, ich habe keine 700 Stalker.
Naja, dann müssen wir sie so erzählen.
Erzähl ihr einfach so. Wir haben uns tierisch Mühe gegeben und jetzt erzählen wir es trotzdem.
Also, ihr kennt die Geschichte von StudiVZ.
StudiVZ hat auch den Spitznamen StalkerVZ. Oder StasiVZ. Ja, aber die StalkerVZ-Geschichte ist die, dass sich eine Gruppe von überwiegend männlichen Teilnehmern gebildet hat, die sich einen Sport gemacht haben, Daten von Frauen, in Anführungszeichen den schärfsten Frauen, zu sammeln und quasi eine Misswahl zu veranstalten. Das Pikante an der Sache war, dass es nicht nur öffentliche Bilder waren, sondern dass es mit einem kleinen Trick, wenn man da in der URL, in der Adresse, ein bisschen was verändert hat, konnten man eben auch auf private Fotos zugreifen. Oder, ja, man konnte also jedenfalls einfach ein bisschen, ohne jetzt großartig loszuhacken zu müssen, einfach Bilder auch aufrufen, die jetzt nicht für die Öffentlichkeit gedacht waren, die als privat markiert waren. Und darauf erinnert sich eben diese Gruppe von, ja, eigentlich von, glaube ich nur Männer, schätze ich mal, gebildet, die sich da so einen Spaß draus gemacht haben, diese Frauenbilder dann ohne deren Wissen und deren Einwilligung dann auch.
Das war schon eine Form von Belästigung. Und dann gab es diese großen Aktionen. Daraufhin hat dann irgendwann Studi4Zoff wirklich mal reagiert und versucht zusammen mit ihren Usern diesen Verhaltenskodex rauszubilden. Aber lange Zeit war da auch wieder Schweigen im Walde. Also da haben sich echt einige Gruppen gebildet, die man schon als echt bizarr bezeichnen muss.
Und Holzbring zahlt 50 Millionen, also eine unglaublich große Summe Geld, um sich da irgendwie 700 bekloppte Stalker ranzuholen. Komische Welt. Wir hören The Broadbands, God Save the Internet und danach reden wir mit euch weiter unter der 0331 7097 110. The Broadband's Got to Save the Internet, das schließen wir uns gerne an. Chaosradio auf Fritz Nummer 134, der nächste am Telefon ist Arthur. Hallo Arthur.
Hallo.
Wir reden über soziale Netzwerke, haben sehr viele Für und Wider gehabt. Auf welcher Seite stehst du?
Na ich bin eigentlich mehr oder weniger dagegen, obwohl ich jetzt sag mal für unsere Band, also meine Band, ich hab auch eine Band, von sehr großen Nutzern, auch bei MySpace, da muss sehr viel, also ich bin sogar zart, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mich hier umkuckele.
Also ziehst du für deine Band auch Nutzen daraus? Aber warum bist du dann dagegen?
Aus der Region. Ich mein jetzt so die ganzen Sachen so wie Knudels und so, also ich weiß nicht, ob das geht. Ich find das einfach nur total, boah, das ist, ich weiß nicht. Also ich bin da selber mal gewesen und ich muss echt sagen, das ist so ein Suchtmachprogramm für, ich sag mal jetzt, 13- 14-Jährige, weil man da ja irgendwelche Ränge haben kann mit irgendwelchen Minuten, die man lang da on ist und so. Und das find ich einfach nur abwartig da, auch weil ja, wie weiß ich.
Aber glaub, wenn man das verbieten oder abschaffen würde, würde das doch nicht daran ändern.
Ja klar, dann würden da halt sich irgendwas anderes ausdenken, ja klar. Aber was ich auch so halt krass finde, also ich bin da nur bei drei Sachen, bei MeistBelt, Abgefuckt und halt SchülerCC und wir haben Abgefuckt, gibt dich die, so ein Punker-Forum drin. So und, ja und die ist halt krass, da ist halt ab Freitag war ein Punker-Treff und bellt sich. Und wir halt da, na ihr wisst, eine große Zahl aus Potsdam und Berlin hingefahren. Uns wurde ein Platz gesagt, wo wir hin sollen, da standen alles voller Bullen. Und die haben uns später am Abend noch irgendwann noch gesagt, das sieht aus, dass sie ein Internet haben.
Aha, da liest er so.
Die Polizei benutzt das Internet, das ist ja unglaublich.
Ja, weil es wurde auch große Flan im Internet rumheben, angekündigt und so. Und das finde ich ganz schön krass.
Ich wusste nicht, dass es schon Social Networks für Punks gibt.
Ich wollte mal richtig ein Profil haben, mit allem Drum und Dran, was ich auch habe.
Hast du Bikini-Fotos von dir oder so? Bikini-Fotos.
Du im Bikini hast du nicht, sag mal ganz schnell dein Myspace-Profil.
Geld-Tower-Wikinger.
Aber sag mal, bei Myspace ist das dein Band-Profil oder dein persönliches?
Mein privater Profil war auch richtig lang, groß, aufwendig gemacht, also, keine Ahnung, auch aus langer Weile, mehr oder weniger. Ich bin mich auch nur auf drei mittlerweile beschränkt, weil ich bin bestimmt bei Misses Acht Dinge angemeldet gewesen und mich alles auf den Sack gejangert.
Sollen wir nochmal Myspace wie Wikinger?
Wikinger wie Wikinger halt und Geld-Tower wie das Dorf, also Geld-Tower.
Bevor wir rufen sie gerade erst auf, hast du irgendwas da drin, wo du dir vielleicht sagst, ok, wenn ich in 20 Jahren mal Kinder habe, dann wäre mir das ganz schön unangenehm?
Und im Radio vorlesen könnten wir das jetzt auch alles? Auch die Sachen, die jetzt da so in deinem privaten Profil sind?
Ich glaube, er ist einfach ein großer Sit-Wishes-Fan, überall Pistols-Fotos rum.
Sit-Wishes?
Volle Kanone. Ist das schon mal Newter Anfang?
Ja, nee, wie gesagt, das ist total krass, auch von polizeilicher Seite, auch an euch schon sehr auf die Spülung gekommen, das ist jetzt schon alt, ihr wusst wohl teilweise.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen blöd? Ist das nicht ein bisschen blöd?
Ja, definitiv und deswegen...
Beim nächsten Mal besser planen?
Ja, deswegen, das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Arthur, danke für den Anruf.
Der Christian Ullman. Und die Kathrin Thüring.
Mensch, die Leitungen glühen wieder, ne?
Der Blue Moon mit Christian Ullman und Kathrin Thüring.
Die Frage, mit der wir uns in den kommenden zwei Stunden beschäftigen werden, lautet...
Tja, das hängt ganz von euch ab.
Habt ihr unfassbar spannende, oft gestellte, doch nie geklärte und vor allem ganz schön verzwickte Fragen? Dann schickt sie per Mail mit Name und Telefonnummer an wissen-at-fritz.de und seid live dabei, wenn es wieder heißt, woher sollen wir das wissen? Morgen Abend ab 22 Uhr.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Die Antwort ist...
Und das wird...
Drei nach halb zwölf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Alexandra Wann.
Die Bundesregierung stellt mehr Geld zur Verfügung, um den Hunger in der Welt zu bekämpfen. Entwicklungsministerin Vychorek Zäul sagte dem Ernährungsprogramm der Vereinten Nationen zusätzlich 10 Millionen Euro zu. Nach Ansicht von Bundeskanzlerin Merkel kann der Anstieg der Lebensmittelpreise nur durch ein gemeinsames internationales Vorgehen eingedämmt werden. Deshalb soll sich auch der nächste G8-Gipfel mit dem Thema befassen. In mehreren Ländern hatte es in den vergangenen Wochen gewaltsame Proteste gegeben, weil sich Menschen ihre Grundnahrungsmittel nicht mehr leisten können. BVG-Kunden müssen auch morgen und in den nächsten Tagen mit Ausfällen und Verspätungen rechnen. Weil die Werkstätten bestreikt werden, könnten die Fahrpläne ausgedünnt und Linien verkürzt werden, kündigte BVG-Sprecherin Reetz an. Die U- und Straßenbahnen sollen zwar nach Plan fahren, allerdings sind sie mit weniger Waggons unterwegs. Unterdessen einigten sich heute die BVG und die Gewerkschaft Verdi vor dem Arbeitsgericht Berlin darüber, dass Streiks künftig rechtzeitig angekündigt werden. Der Bundesnachrichtendienst steht wegen der Bespitzelung einer Journalistin zunehmend in der Kritik. Am Wochenende war bekannt geworden, dass der BND im Jahr 2006 monatelang den E-Mail-Verkehr einer Spiegelreporterin überwacht hatte. Das Kontrollgremium des Bundestages befragte heute BND-Chef Urlaut zu dem Fall. Die Untersuchung soll morgen fortgesetzt werden. Politiker der CSU und der Grünen schließen einen Rücktritturlaus nicht aus. Fußball. In der Champions League haben sich der FC Barcelona und Manchester United 0 zu 0 unentschieden getrennt. Das Hinspiel des Halbfinales lief in Spanien. Das Rückspiel findet am kommenden Dienstag in England statt. Und Basketball. In der Basketball-Bundesliga konnten sich die Berliner durchsetzen. Alba gewann im Auswärtsspiel gegen Ludwigsburg 74 zu 73. Und auch in der Handball-Bundesliga gibt es einen Sieg für die Berliner. Die Füchse Berlin besiegten Schlusslicht Wilhelmshaven mit 26 zu 23 und können damit auch nicht mehr absteigen. In der Nacht ist es locker bewölkt und trocken bei Tiefstwerten von 6 bis 1 Grad. Morgen gibt es erstmal viel Sonnenschein, später aber auch ein paar Wolken in Regen soll es aber nicht. Das Ganze bei 16 bis maximal 19 Grad. Alles ist frei, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Null so im Spiel, ein Stück vom neuen Album von Catcar Sylt, Chaosradio 134, Constanze Frank sind hier vom CCC, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden mit euch über soziale Netzwerke, die Myface, Spick, VZ, Ing, Book, Comm, Slash, Communities, wie sie dann alle heißen, wo Leute ihr halbes Leben oder ihr ganzes Leben online stellen, wo Personalchefs, wie auch heute gerade in der Sendung gehört, gerne auch mal nachgucken und sagen, Sie wollen also einen Job bei uns, Sie haben ja schon mal auf einer Party geschielt und sich daneben benommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich funktioniert oder wie wir es eben gerade gehört haben, wo die Polizei einfach mitguckt, wo die nächsten großen Punkertreffen stattfinden und dann schon vor der versammelten Mannschaft da ist. Was haltet ihr davon? Wie geht ihr mit der Problematik vom Datenschutz um und warum seid ihr überhaupt in diesen Netzwerken? Das wollen wir wissen. 0331 70 97 110. Hallo nach München. Hallo Ralf. Jetzt kann ich aber sagen Servus, oder? Nee, weil er München ist.
Na, ich weiß es nicht so genau.
Ich bin sozusagen ein Neumünchner.
Ach du bist ein Nike-Hokter. Oh, aber wenn du nach München gezogen bist und da neu bist, heißt es, dass du von woanders kommst, einen Freundeskreis woanders zurückgelassen hast und den jetzt übers Netz weiter pflegst?
Ja, gut, das ist ein Aspekt. Was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte ist, ich war neulich bei einer ganz interessanten Veranstaltung, und zwar eine Kodiumsdiskussion zu dem Thema, dass entweder der Privatheit wie unsere Daten im Internet verteilt werden. Und das war eigentlich eine juristische Tagung. Und da war aber ein sehr interessanter Mann dabei, der hieß Gersfried Stocker, das war ein Künstler. Und der hat da ganz interessante Aspekte in die Debatte reingeworfen.
Welche denn?
Und zwar, also er meinte, ja, das ist einfach ein gesellschaftliches Problem. Im Moment regt uns das auf, aber die Gesellschaft wird das noch lernen mit solchen sozialen Netzwerken, zum Beispiel umzugehen mit diesen Daten, die sie da öffentlich machen. Und das dauert einfach ein bisschen. Also das ganze Internet, das ist noch sehr jung. Und wenn man jetzt mal, also er hat auch so schön verglichen mit dem Autoverkehr zum Beispiel, dass es heute, ist das auch ganz normal, dass wir unsere Kinder erstmal an die Hand nehmen und denen erstmal erklären, was ein Zebrastreifen ist. Und irgendwann können die auch selber sich im Straßenverkehr bewegen. Und mit dem Internet ist das halt noch nicht so weit. Da wissen die Eltern selber noch nicht, wie es funktioniert und können es deshalb auch ihren Kindern nicht weitergeben.
Also das ist dann im Prinzip eine Kompetenzfrage, oder?
Bitte?
Das wäre also für dich auf jeden Fall eine Kompetenzfrage und eine Ausbildungsfrage.
Genau, das muss man einfach lernen. Und wenn jetzt die Generation, die jetzt so sorglos mit ihren Daten da in Schüler-VZ und Studi-VZ umgeht, wenn die mal auf die Fresse gefallen ist und dann ihren Enkeln das dann mal näherbringen können, wie das damals war und so weiter, dann haben wir es wahrscheinlich geschafft.
Du meinst, das ist so ein Evolutionsprozess. Ich denke, es ist ja nicht unbedingt eine Entwicklung, die wir jetzt vielleicht gut heißen sollten, dass die Leute dazu tendieren, immer mehr Daten reinzustellen und dass es auch ganz selbstverständlich ist, persönliche Daten in so ein Netz reinzustellen. Das ist ja genau wie beim Autoverkehr. Nur weil wir jetzt unsere Kinder auf dem Schulweg an die Hand nehmen und zeigen, dass sie nach links und nach rechts gucken müssen, heißt es ja nicht, dass wir das gut finden, dass sie später unbedingt auch selbst viele Autos fahren, sondern würden ihnen auch gerne beibringen, vielleicht öffentlich Verkehrsmittel zu nehmen, weil das umweltfreundlicher ist oder so. Und genauso ist es auch bei den Netzwerken. Also nur, dass wir jetzt sagen, wir lernen damit umzugehen, heißt es ja nicht, dass wir das unbedingt gut finden, da jetzt die exzentiv zu nutzen und da ganz viel reinzustellen von sich.
Beziehungsweise, oder um es anders, um so viel Laksat zu formulieren, macht euch nicht so heiß, das wechselt irgendwann raus.
Nee, man wird halt lernen, dass man halt die Sachen reinstellt, dass man halt die Sachen veröffentlicht, die man auch veröffentlichen will. Dann wird sich dann halt mit der Zeit bilden.
Wobei wir heute auch schon das Thema hatten, dass nicht mal du selber Sachen online stellst, sondern irgendjemand, du warst auf einer Party, auf einem Geburtstag oder auf einem Konzert, wo auch immer, und es tauchen Fotos von dir auf, die irgendjemand gemacht hat, und die stehen dann bei denen auf der Seite, und damit bist du ja trotzdem dabei. Da hast du keine Entscheidung gehabt, ob du sagst, du möchtest das oder möchtest das nicht.
Ja, es lösen sich nicht alle Probleme wahrscheinlich.
Das passiert mir persönlich regelmäßig, dass ich irgendwo bin, wenn ich einen Vortrag halte, dass jemand bei Flickr dann ein Bild reinstellt, davon meinem Namen tickt. In der Regel sind die sehr nett, wenn man sie bittet, das rauszunehmen, aber das passiert mir eigentlich sehr regelmäßig. Wo du sagst, dass du auf der Tagung warst, sind da eigentlich auch so Probleme wie dieses Konzept des Vergessenes, das mit der in der digitalen Welt dann weg ist, angesprochen worden? Also dass die ja auch bleiben.
Das Problem, dass man halt Sachen, die man einmal reingestellt hat, nicht mehr rausklickt. Genau, das wurde auch angesprochen. Und da ist auch wiederum ein interessanter Aspekt. Also man sagt immer so, die Daten sind in der Öffentlichkeit und für jedermann einsehbar. Aber genau genommen ist es eigentlich gar nicht die Öffentlichkeit. Also jedenfalls nicht das, was man aus der Offline-Welt unter Öffentlichkeit versteht, sondern der hat das genannt, das sind eigentlich Corporate Spaces. Ja, aber vergleichbar hat er gesagt, fand ich ganz schön, wie die Landlords damals in der Feudalherrschaft. So ähnlich kann man sich das vorstellen. Also ich gebe dann meine Daten irgendwie dem Rupert Murdoch und der kann damit im Prinzip machen, was er will. Jedenfalls gelten aber Privatgesetze und keine öffentlichen Gesetze. Es ist nicht die Öffentlichkeit, sondern ich bin bei einer Firma.
Ja, richtig.
Also er betont diesen kommerziellen Aspekt dann.
Aber dadurch, dass du mit einem Haufen Leuten weltweit kommunizierst, hast du das Gefühl, dass das die Öffentlichkeit wäre.
Genau, aber es ist gar nicht die Öffentlichkeit. Und dann, also so gegen Ende war es dann auch recht tröstlich wieder, dass er dann meinte, naja es wird sich mit der Zeit, wenn sich dieses Bewusstsein wandelt, wenn das den Leuten bewusster wird, wird die Nachfrage nach besseren Produkten mit mehr Datenschutz steigen und dann wird der Markt halt reagieren. Und dann werden halt nachher solche Netzwerke verstärkt vertreten sein, die halt solche Sachen ernst nehmen. Und wo man halt auch Sachen wieder rauslöschen kann, wo man her seiner Daten ist und so weiter.
Andererseits, wenn MySpace oder Studi4Z oder wie sie auch immer heißen, jetzt schon gelernt haben, dass die Leute ihnen die Daten freiwillig hinterherschmeißen und dass sie damit einen Haufen Geld verdienen, warum sollten sie später zurück rudern? Der einzige Grund wäre, dass die User sich alle...
Wenn jetzt mehr Leute ihren Account löschen...
Genau, das wäre der einzige Grund, dass ihnen die Kunden weglaufen.
Genau, die Leute wechseln zu Plattformen, die seriöser sind. Gut, aber die Frage ist, ob seriöse Plattformen, wo die Leute nicht so viele Daten angeben, dann noch laufen. Weil diese Plattformen leben ja nun mal davon, dass die Leute da ihren Zeugs reinstellen, ihre Daten, behaupte ich mal.
Ja sicher, aber ich finde, ein ganz schönes Beispiel ist Xing zum Beispiel. Oder wie spricht man es jetzt aus? Also da gibt es ja doch schon etwas Gesitte dazu. Hat man jedenfalls so das Gefühl, wenn man sich da bewegt. Und also gut, die Leute geben auch nicht so viel von sich preis.
Na das ist ja wohl ein Witz, oder? Die geben nicht so viel von sich preis?
Nee, die geben aber Sachen von sich preis, wo man das Gefühl hat, die sind sich bewusst, dass sie das bewusst machen wollen. Also wenn ich da meine Berufshistorie reinschreibe oder solche Sachen, das ist was anderes, als wenn ich da meine Partybilder reinschreibe. Oder Fotos.
Gerade bei Crossing bin ich mir sicher, dass den Leuten es sogar überbewusst ist, was sie reinstellen. Ich will sagen, sie stellen damit sogar absichtlich Sachen rein. Also wir haben zwei ganz interessante E-Mails bekommen, eine von Nicole, die meinte, sie benutzt halt dieses Netz, um einfach auch wirklich beruflich Kontakte zu knüpfen. Und das kennen wir auch aus unserem Umfeld auch, wo einfach viele Leute, die als Selbstständige, als Freiberufler unterwegs sind, für dieses ein ganz, ganz wichtige Jobplattform mittlerweile geworden. Wobei man natürlich auch wieder sehr vorsichtig sein muss, was die Leute da reinstellen. Also ich kann ja auch sehr bewusst mein Profil da verändern. Und wenn es erstmal etabliert ist, dann kann es mir bei einer Werbung möglicherweise auch helfen, dass die Leute gucken, ah, der hat ja da eine ganz interessante Vergangenheit. Ob die stimmt, das wird dann vielleicht manchmal gar nicht mehr nachgeprüft, weil der denkt, oh, prima, der hat ja hier irgendwie 500 Freunde oder sowas. Und die können das ja alle bestätigen. Das ist vielleicht auch nochmal eine ganz interessante Gefahr, aber in die andere Richtung.
Es ist auch nicht unbedingt frei von privaten Daten. Natürlich findet man da nicht die Saufgelage, jedenfalls sehr selten. Aber was man wohlfindet, sind auch sehr viele private Daten, etwa über Kinder oder über Lebensumstände, die manchmal da man annimmt, dass es sich für Bewerbungen einfach positiv macht, wenn man diese sozialen Aspekte mit rein nimmt, angegeben werden. Oder aber auch sehr genaue Angaben darüber, an welchen genauen Projekten man gearbeitet hat. Also dass die Arbeitsvita so spezifisch dargestellt wurde, dass man sich da auch fragen muss, sind das eigentlich Erwachsene, die da ihre Profile angeben? Wollen die das? Das ist sicherlich, denke ich, auch noch mal ein bisschen fragwürdig. Gerade weil es ja hier nicht um Jugendliche geht, die vielleicht darüber nicht so viel nachdenken, sondern um erwachsene Leute.
Aber es ist ja halt nicht nur schlecht, wenn man da sein Profil etwas aufmotzt. Man hat ja auch Vorteile von, etwa indem man dann angesprochen wird, sie sind auch Experte für dieses oder jenes.
Also um das kurz zusammenzufassen, Ralf, die steigende Nachfrage nach einem seriösen Produkt wird irgendwann den Markt von selber regeln.
Na ja, ich möchte dir doch ein bisschen bezweifeln.
Wollen wir mal hoffen, dass es so wird. Eben, eben. Danke und schöne Abend nach München.
Vielleicht ganz kurz noch eine Mail vom Stefan. Der hat nämlich einen interessanten Aspekt eingebracht, wenn man seine persönlichen Daten nicht in so irgendeinen Social Network eingeben will, dann macht man einfach sein eigenes auf. Es gibt nämlich mittlerweile eine ganze Menge von Software, womit man, wenn man sich ein bisschen auskennt, mit vielleicht Linux, bis in das Thema Administration sowas einrichten kann, kann man einfach sein eigenes kleines soziales Netzwerk aufbauen und alle seine Freunde einladen und kann sich darüber freuen.
Wo jetzt auf der anderen Seite wieder die faulen Unprogrammierer kommen und sagen, oh davon hat der ein E, dann mach ich das schnell hier irgendwo im Internet. Hallo Thomas, guten Abend. Du rufst von wo an?
Aus Berlin.
Aus Berlin, bist du online vernetzt?
Ja, also nicht so direkt über die sozialen Netzwerke, mehr so ein bisschen Instant-Messaging und Foren. Aber was ich kurz sagen wollte, also wir haben ja nicht mehr sehr viel Zeit, und zwar habe ich vor über 2 Jahren meine Halbschwester über StayFriends wiederhebunden. Ja, war irgendwie ziemlich spannend. Also wir haben uns sehr kalt geschrieben, dann ging es ein bisschen unterher per Mail und ja, dann bek ich halt hin und auf einmal merkt man halt, dass man eine Schwester hat, die man vorher gar nicht kannte, oder? Und dazu halt dann Schwager und Neffen und Nichten und so.
Was war der Grund für dich, dich da anzumelden bei StayFriends?
Ich seh jetzt gar nicht mehr. Ich glaube, ich hab's irgendwo gefunden, fand's dann so interessant und hab dann auch gesehen, dass ein paar aus meiner Ehe mal in Schule da waren, oder aus den Schulen. Und hab mir dann ein Profil hingerichtet und war dann ein bisschen überrascht, als ich da so kam.
Also für dich damit auf jeden Fall ein positiver Aspekt.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Siehst du Negative oder hast du bisher eigentlich nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht?
Also ich persönlich eigentlich nur gute, aber vielleicht auch deswegen, weil ich mich an den Profilen immer ein bisschen zurückhalte. Zum Beispiel mein ICQ-Profil ist ziemlich alt. Also ich update nicht wirklich, weil, naja.
Okay, du passt also ein bisschen auf von deiner Seite aus.
Man muss ja halt nicht mitreden schreiben, wo man wohnt.
Ja genau, unter die Handynummer dazu tun.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn die Polizei sich dann doch mal das Internet ausdruckt.
Jetzt würde man aber daran merken, dass plötzlich in der ganzen Stadt Druckerpatronen alle sind.
Außerdem wissen wir halt so nicht, was auf den Google-Cash-Seiten alles so liegen bleibt.
Oder Archive Ork oder...
Und wie lange die behalten und wo die überall hinverkauft wird, ich meine, realt ja keiner drüber.
Aber die Geschichte mit deiner Halbschwester ist natürlich wieder ein großes Plus auf der anderen Seite. Ist wieder der Ausgleich zu der Geschichte von dem Personalchef von Porsche. Die fand ich echt krass. Danke Thomas. Wir könnten ganz kurz in ein leichtes Resümee ziehen schon mal.
Na ja, eigentlich war ganz interessant mal zu hören, wie...
Was heißt hier eigentlich?
Das war eine super Sendung. Einfach wie die Zuhörer selber Hand haben. Und wie, eigentlich aus meiner Sicht, das wird überraschend, auch uneigentlich, wie doch, wie balanciert hier gesprochen wurde. Also einerseits, dass man eben doch nicht so doll die Profile von sich selbst anlegt, aber eben die positiven Aspekte sieht.
Du hältst ja auch viele Vorlesungen an Unis und auch an Schulen zu diesem und anderen Themen. Deckt sich das mit dem, was du bislang so an Resonanz bekommen hast?
Das kann ich eigentlich nicht unbedingt sagen. An den Schulen ist das eher so, die Schüler sind in der Regel ein bisschen jünger, dass man das sagen muss, die sind ein bisschen unbekümmert da. Ich kenne natürlich auch sehr krasse Fälle, wo Drogen gegen Lehrer gab, wo sich einfach der Klassenkollektiv ganz negativ zusammengefunden hat und wo dann auch an der Schule ein Eklage gab. Also es gibt schon auch echt schlimme Fälle. Meine Erfahrung ist einfach schlicht, dass die gesamte Klasse sich da einfindet in diesen sozialen Netzwerken. Bei den jüngeren Studenten ist das eigentlich das Gleiche. Da ist es aber eher ein bisschen zielorientiert, weil die tauschen halt Übungsaufgaben und reden über die Vorlesung.
Ich glaube, wenn alle Nutzer von diesen Netzwerken so vorsichtig wären wie die Anrufer, die wir jetzt hatten, dann wären diese ganzen Datenpannen nicht passiert.
Also ich bin überrascht.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht repräsentativ. Oder die ganzen Storys stimmen natürlich nicht, oder sind vielleicht alle gar nicht so schlimm zu bewerten. Aber das ist eine Sache, das müsst ihr dann selbst wissen. Also wenn ihr das Profil habt, wenn ihr da euer Profil zusammenklickt, denkt nochmal drüber nach. Mehr können wir eigentlich auch gar nicht sagen und wollen wir auch gar nicht.
Also wenn ihr den Eisbären immer mit Zuckerstückchen füttert, braucht ihr euch nicht wundern, wenn Knut irgendwann bei euch im Badezimmer steht. Das Schlusswort kriegt Daniel. Hallo Daniel. Okay, Daniel ist beschäftigt beim Fußball. Dann können wir jetzt nur noch sagen, das war Chaosradio Nummer 134. Hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ihr könnt es nochmal nachhören. Als Podcast zum Beispiel auf chaosradio.cc.de. Da gibt's auch das Wiki und da gibt's die anderen Sendungen und da gibt's Chaosradio Express und Chaosradio TV.
Wir haben jetzt gar nicht über YouTube geredet. Möchtet ihr mich beschweren zum Ende? Zumal YouTube ja wohl den höchsten Preis erzielt hat, wenn ich das mal anmerken darf, mit 1, 65 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Die haben nix. Ich meine, die haben nicht mal ne Community so richtig.
Ja, aber die haben 100 Millionen Videos täglich.
Von denen sie keine Rechte haben.
Also ich denke, das wird immer viel vergessen, dass ja auch diese, naja, kleinen Videos, die auch ein Leben beschreiben, wo es einfach dutzende Leute gibt, die täglich da ihre Messages reinmengen, dass das ja auch ne Form von Social Community ist, und dass man eben versucht, über Bloggen und aber auch über Video reinstellen, da sich so Leute zusammen zu holen, denen man so ne täglichen Geschichten erzählen kann.
Was absolut legitim und total in Ordnung ist. Ich halte das für absolut falsch, wenn Leute sagen, hier diese ganzen sozialen Netzwerke und MySpace, Spick, Ing, Dings, Bums, VZ, das ist alles der Satan.
Wer sagt denn das noch?
Verteufeln bringt immer auf.
Du wirst die Stimme immer wieder mal finden.
Ja, wir hören es hier, klar, natürlich. Der CCC wird immer wieder angesprochen, sagt, ihr seid doch hier die Datenschützer und ihr müsst hier mal ein Machtwort sprechen. Kommt die Leute zu uns. Und wir stehen aber auch da her, wir nutzen die ja auch. Man muss halt aufpassen.
Wir hören halt beim CCC doch öfter mal auch die traurigen Geschichten. Also wenn sich Opfer schon mal an uns, da haben wir manchmal schon sehr krasse Fälle.
Also Leute, die Stalking-Opfer geworden sind.
Oder wo sich eben plötzlich so ein Klassenverband gegen sie wendet und eben eine Person aus der Klasse da übel behandelt wird. Oder wo sie eben mal ganz konkret erfahren, wie bei der Freundin, die eine Studentin war, die eigentlich schwanger war und ihr Blog geschrieben hat. Also sowas gibt es natürlich mal. Oder auch mal, wo die Probleme haben in Naziforen. Das ist aber schon mal ganz schön blöd, oder?
Also mal ehrlich.
Na ja, gut, also...
Also dass der Personalchef mal im Internet nachguckt, da muss ja schon mitrechnen.
Ich hätte natürlich auch nicht gemacht. Aber nun, die melden sich dann, wenn sie ein Problem haben. Also wir kriegen öfter mal so die Opfer ab. Die kommen dann manchmal in Klub gelaufen oder schreiben eine Mail. Und sagen, was ihnen schlimmer passiert ist. Und man kann immer nur hoffen, dass sie aus dem Schaden klug werden.
Und vielleicht vorher dreimal überlegen, wenn man Dinge ins Netz stellt, weil irgendwann kommt es...
Bevor man Enter drückt, nochmal nachdenken.
ob man wirklich möchte oder nicht. Hier geht jetzt nichts zurück. Hier geht es jetzt weiter. Und zwar mit Night Flight, mit... Warte mal, mit Stino von der True Beats Crew. Und mit Joachim Masaplan-Mofo. Der Mann mit der geilsten Witzung dieser Welt. Max hat es mir aufgeschrieben. Ich soll es genauso vorlesen und habe es gemacht. Die letzte Nummer kommt von National Bank. Playlist ist online auf fritz.de. Wir hören uns dann an anderer Stelle wieder. Habt eine schöne Zeit.
So, das war das schönste Chaosradio der Welt mit meinem Freund Jakob Kaffekränzchen. Und er hat natürlich jetzt irgendwie uns angesagt. Es stimmt natürlich wieder alles überhaupt gar nicht, deswegen lasst euch gerade vom Chaos keinen Scheiß erzählen. Denn ihr hört immer noch den besten Sender in der ganzen Stadt, der FRITZ heißt. Und mein Name, den erfahrt ihr gleich.